[Music]
hello I'm in the cellar could a guy
remember so you don't have no bad well
Regis reshoot right what are you guys
doing here
and Todd says we need to redo the review
authority do you see the department of
cameos remember when you made the
trailer for this review the one with the
pop song you mean the one I was told to
do like another comic book trailer that
may or may not have a talking raccoon in
its we can't confirm nor deny that well
it was a big hit and we need to add more
comedy you're changing halfway just
because a competitor is doing better
well DC is usually a few months behind
years decade it's okay we're doing it
for cents
doing what cutting out what they like
the most let's go GOP on this sucker now
since we're corporate more humor
obviously get to drop the clown well it
goes without saying oh I wouldn't do
that why not
hi-yah Jin's been playing Joker offset
like Jared Leto did on the movie oh by
the way here you go yeah he mailed a
shit like Leto too
because the real Joker would do that oh
look anal be yeah just like the real
master of crime how is this even funny
but you were supposed to be funny
nah cuz there you're holding anal beach
your authentic grills are falling out
well nah man amazing practice you sure
they aren't just plastic tears coming at
amazing prize listen Jim Jim Christina
sounds like handsome guy Joker Jared
Leto Klang Joker yeah I would have come
let me took a Tacoma everytime yeah
listen we appreciate that you're trying
to create buzz but doesn't the Joker
murder people and blow up buildings yeah
that's like dangerous I'd rather just
pretend it oh just like the real Joker
yeah so uh while you're pretending to do
that other stuff why don't you also
pretend that you're doing this second
grader discovering what a troll is stick
well
wouldn't be able to act like an asshole
for no reason
oh just like the real Jared Leto Oh God
yeah so that's totally justified
I'm deeper than I thought which I can
also save those anal beads Scooby Doo a
name cut him how you can cut them out
all you want
oh great so we're also going to have to
redo the opening credits what
all right that ain't half bad nothing
says dark and green we like bright neon
all right let's just get me hyped up I'm
ready for action
negative our church show that some
people prefer when you sit at a desk and
do nothing
come on wouldn't wanna start Suicide
Squad with someone just sitting down for
20 minutes just talking about the main
characters so we start Suicide Squad
with someone sitting down for 20 minutes
just talking about the main characters
her name is Amanda played by Viola Davis
she's an intelligence officer with an
idea so insane just crazy enough not to
work who do we call when the next
Superman comes to take us out
Wonder Woman no the flesh no Aquaman no
sidewalk no but no Lego Batman how about
the villains those heroes fought no no
even though that would arguably save
hundreds of life that's not what happens
they actually hear her out if another
person as strong as Superman comes we
have to be ready are you seriously
telling me that supervillains will do
less harm than Superman did you forget
how good metropolis looked after
Superman saved it from Zod okay everyone
let's look at these crazy our first mug
shot is Deadshot damn there's assassin
around impossible Savior wolf move
terrific it also turns out the other
daughter who knows how to play
peacekeeper when he pisses off the wrong
people
[Music]
it's over tempo Deadshot oh well that's
what we got a lot less cool Oh hopefully
he can tell a little many things he'll
just turn to a cold-hearted monster any
decent anything would immediately lose
affection for yeah well that's never
stopped me before
number by the way kid I'm gonna show
your daddy not you oh sorry
usually when people are angry about a
costume man killing people it's about me
you win kid oh but I wanted to kill him
I then had next on our list is Captain
Boomerang it's pretty much Rocksteady
from Ninja Turtles before he was the
Rhino a superpower
you guessed it boom ah you're going to
take down the next Superman with a
boomerang admittedly it does sound
stupid amazingly stupid
so should we distract it when I tell you
that the flashes in this movie hello
Oh
what is that disgusting reptilian Beast
that's the reason turbo gonna have to
call us Academy award-winning Suicide
Squad our tickets at best makeup of our
Star Trek film zone
it's scary wonder himself the croc
a Medina
next exemplar who can create fire and
it's worn off on it but we're saving his
backstory for later so we'll just skip
them for now
Polly Queen the Joker's girlfriend
what's her super color fan service
used to be dr. Harley Quinzel she was
assigned to the clown himself he got us
out of mind and made her a dangerous
killer
okay are you reading her criminal record
or her trading card oh I guess for
trading card well what does her criminal
records say about how she can help us um
you have a mouth okay Lachlan okay last
one The Enchantress a young doctor went
exploring in a cave and got possessed by
an evil witch she wants to take over the
world and may have the power to do so
under our control though she's the most
powerful thing online
and that's all you need what The
Enchantress that's all you need you can
get the rest of that binder into the
garbage hey I worked hard to find the
worst of the worst and you came across
boomerangs mallets guns a petting zoo
and a guy who makes fire who no longer
makes fire this is all you need all your
attention should be on her he's right we
don't need to worry about them as long
as you have that witch odor control yeah
what do you got her under lockdown or
military surveillance better we have one
guy looking after her in a hotel room
what's up that's clearly not enough one
moron
I can assure you it's okay I can call to
prove it
oh hi colonel Amanda here I was just
wondering how with that Oh aha oh just
let me know how that works out
so what appears she's escaped who would
know a person that they don't taking
over the world will try to rule the
world while that's going on one of them
think you really mean security guards
played by Ike Barinholtz is given a
surprise visit and as all time by mr. J
I can't wait to show you my toys I know
you mailed me your anal beads last week
that was y'all the new me wants to show
you my actual scary toy
we're not going to see them are we know
that seems been cut as well as this of
course but that doesn't mean that I
can't hurt you
lobstery Oh knock it off Jim and let
Walter go but I thought about ways said
Greek I need to get more psychotic to
get into character in fact you look on
your desk you might find another
president left or right a dead mouse oh
yeah you're really open your Dame there
well not just anything doesn't look a
little familiar like a certain have at
home is my girlfriend you can keep the
knife what nice the guard does however
come through on his prize yes they do
ship a boyfriend so to give you that oh
how sweet you're in so much trouble big
trouble
what kind of trouble what's gonna happen
to me
nothing happens - yeah he disappears
from the film altogether in fact ah
another one of our brilliant cuts we
fizzled that diddle for shizzle Madison
yeah but literally any payoff would have
worked here and no matter how tiny the
choker could lob it home or take him out
while on a run sport says he's fond of
mailing things he could get this in the
mail many of those you don't understand
critic we're doing it for the fans yeah
you keep saying that what does that
excuse me it means we don't have to
explain that much because the fans
already know like look at this character
on their mission I am guitar and my
sword holds the souls of the enemies
that I kill with it here's a clip of me
doing something you see that's all they
need to know know when you gather stats
and back stories down but we don't know
her what's her personality interest
dislikes character traits it's not like
say an x-files movie where the
characters are already established in a
TV show this is a different
interpretation that needs to be
established look I know our competitors
may or may not have a talking record
give their characters individual movies
and then put them together into one that
makes audiences understand them better
and cheer for them when they come
together I totally forgot where I was
going with this however our fans don't
need that because they've got the comics
Gandalf would be so much stronger if
they replaced him with the Lord of the
Rings paperback and said come on you
know this guy right in fact we were even
toying with the idea of replacing every
character in this movie with recommended
issue numbers that way they can read up
on the characters and we don't even have
to write them so while you may think for
the fans means lazy we like to think it
means
not that name one personality trade of
Catan no I don't know at a recounts so
the guy watching The Enchantress who
also happens to be in love with her is
Rick Flagg this guy is like for the main
character in Godzilla and they so
forgettable you probably don't even
realize this isn't Ford from Godzilla
this is because he can pretty much be
switched out with anyone I'm just going
to play his part you why you because the
characters can be introduced with no
rhyme or reason why can't I be one he's
picked by The Enchantress to break out
of a man of control along with her
resurrected brother it's called for the
most unqualified people in the world
so he leads his team of villains to stop
the Enchantress from taking over the
world and wait a minute how come I
didn't get any bright credits or
backstory Oh what the Native American
guy doesn't get any attention oh no
nothing like that
I'm just here to die aren't I no yes it
is you're going to use the remote in
that hand to blow up the chip inside my
head everybody has a chip in their head
okay if you tried to escape you die
around nothing willing anyone out I
think he's lying
give it a shot did you hear that he's
trying to kill me
discounts off 10 years trying to kill me
forgot thank you not just here to die
what's my name
oh here it is
Thunder halt Nightwolf increasing
redshirt dances with Loya from Jurassic
Park you know what screw you guys
I'm not dying for any of you assholes
alright bye alphas man throw your chips
out of white guilt you happy
you know you're right killing people
really helps me get into character who
would have thought it was so inspiring
damn it Jim you're a real asshole stop
telling my caste don't blame me blame
the character I know it's a risky method
and people probably won't like me for it
but I thought the sacrifice was
worthless of the character now what are
you doing that's the whole reason why
I'm doing this so I can gloat reporters
but how awesome I get out of here what
do you think about people claiming
you're only doing this for attention
they're right
[Applause]
you
the Suicide Squad make their way towards
the intent
thanks Turan office buildings this
governing tantras is minions okay I know
they're not technically honeys but they
look like them sound like them and
people don't realize how surprisingly
easy they are to kill re just be a lot
shorter if they just shot people we're
not so lucky
all right squad let's fight like we
don't have comfortable career so fall
back on it this movie doesn't do well
wait a minute
I don't think this is dark enough oh me
like there needs to be more twisted
characters or plot lines no ah much
better
now fight yeah I can see you why would
you want you to fight scene in the dark
don't people want see the action again
critic the less we give people the more
they can feel and what's good about it
you wouldn't understand critic it's for
bad well quite the table your way around
this oh wait and then there's Harley
Quinn help
ah
mmm oh yes the professor and Mary Ann
hey hey
as you can see Harley goes in the
elevator well come on wait I'll look at
her like that she bought him off yes
that's what she does so what we hired
her to do why would we bring her and she
couldn't fight anyone off fanservice
fanservice I'm gonna have to say
fanservice
come on it's for the fan man to take
your bike fine
get a sample boxes so Diablo isn't
fighting but their child will meringue
try to convince it both times me oh you
don't want me to touch you
fuck you but Deadshot doesn't realize it
can take years to transform a man who's
worn on fire
Wow I took like nothing yeah I know
is that really all it took to get you
back into violence I don't know here's a
pacifism destroyed by tapping on your
head just don't let people talk to my
head okay it's annoying
well we appreciate your sacrifice yeah
it's like one of those guys going vegan
for a day I know right
pussy please about time you got here oh
right they first had to save Amanda from
being destroyed by the Enchantress's
wrath and you wouldn't have made it here
without them and mini-grid I was right
see that again I was right about the
Suicide Squad you were right
oh yeah you were right you're right
you were happy out there the one that's
destroying the city I'm sure you're
aware her she was part of a certain team
a super team
am I correct yeah uh-huh and there was a
name a name for this certain team if I
recall that that you David correct yeah
and the name of that team again the one
that you gave remember suicide fart
fucking suicide squad Suicide Squad wait
a minute sighs happy it because she's
part of the team you were right about so
close to me if I'm wrong but if this
dream team was never put together the
one you were right about none of this
bullshit would be happening right now
it's almost like all of this in entirely
your goddamn fault
hey if you want the Suicide Squad and
she's part of the Suicide Squad she has
a death beam here it is your so Debbie
here yes all the way over here her test
being reaches oh and nukes your Suicide
Squad I think your real shit I joined up
come on
before I feel like so anything like a
bad better wise seven and as I can film
I thought I was just gonna sit here and
let you say you were right like in the
movie I'm Brendan Rodgers I'm giving you
the freaked out you deserve you friggin
idiot you finished yes efficient you
feel better yeah do come on let's just
help a new Wonder Woman movie better so
the Joker comes to save Harlequin which
many die-hard fans have a problem I
think our nation of the to have the
Joker's reading Harley like garbage I
mean to an N he went bad and I to say
but here's the thing
O'Quinn in terms of Batman lore has not
been around very long
so her story is more open to changes in
the future this is an interpretation
that's different but honestly kind of
interesting we've had plenty of times
where the Joker's been self-centered but
it's actually kind of fascinating to see
him vulnerable and care about the money
it's an aspect of the character not
often explored so regardless of which
one you like better I actually don't
think it's a bad version to have out
there especially because it's pretty
dysfunctional is wet oh my bad
Harley it's okay I'm serious you guys
I'm a dinosaur not just pretty bird
but it looks like the squad was answers
for Rick yours truly look Rick flag or
whatever your real name is actually that
is supposed to be my real name seriously
okay look we need some answers okay the
most powerful entity in the world has
escaped and now wanted to take over the
world yeah we know we saw that thing
yeah you just showed it from a slightly
different angle yeah kind of weird of
repeating that no no the church says
this is where you're supposed to feel
hopeless I'd give up what that doesn't
seem in character with any of us yeah
every day could be our last you know no
no no no this is the part where you have
to feel defeated and push out wait the
bad guys are supposed to push out jiggy
don't say jiggy
I literally invented jiggy Wicky Wicky
wild wild west okay let's go and feel
hopeless I guess
sure I'm feeling hopeless in here it's
not like we risked life and death every
day yeah I'm crazy so I don't know why
I'm here
oh we haven't gotten a line from croc in
a while I'm a dinosaur
so there's that also Diablos back story
we don't know that I killed my entire
family yeah that's about right this
doesn't shock any of you we're bad God
how many times you have to say this damn
movie yeah we should be like she is not
taking over the world we're taking over
the world
yes pull the scene man with the audience
with a goddamn pay for wait you're
supposed to give up on a national speech
super villains by definition are the
most motivated people in the world I'm
not giving in to aim where you've got
the officiate we are going to defeat her
ultimate weapon of a portal in the sky
son of a first cookie I suppose we'll be
putting that movie who is that one
asshole who keeps putting that guy in
there if you giving it white shirt guy
you're the one to keep putting it at all
the film right is it some sort of sick
erotic thrill for you he has a sort
specific fetish for it no critic it's
not that at all now if you'll excuse me
I have some paperwork to do
oh Avengers Oh Fantastic Four Oh
ghostbusters you know my oh my god
cutaway shuttle oh my god where I think
a million one of them decided me the
rest of that scene oh Christ
boom come on let's go from one dark
shadowy location to another dark shadowy
location to boldly go took a squad get
to The Enchantress and try to stop it's
time for you really portal to talk to
the world about my mercy it is the end
of days and what what are you doing what
was just the way that I would why
adjusted who are you gonna do the
Macarena I will just write you all hey
hey you know the whole dancing hula doll
you put on your - I don't think so
because as it turns out I can do this
sorta
what the hell is that thing what the
hell did we know he could turn into this
let me guess
for the fans but the enchantress shows
them the life they always wanted and she
could get them if they only join her
side
[Music]
are you sure nobody called us do you see
the bat-signal tantras its destroyed
we're losing the doctor inside and the
squad go back to prison this time
treated with a little more respect but
there's one more twist let's go home
that's the character we knew was a lie
turns up and naturally quencher ending
but it's the Joker and anything he's in
is immediately amazing look like
anything the Joker done right is amazing
here like everything else in this movie
it's just done passable
despite it being a big hit this movie
divided a lot of audiences some love did
some hated it other thought it was okay
honestly they're all understandable none
of it makes sense and the pacing and
tone feels incredibly inconsistent and I
can't imagine why that is what can we
say except you're welcome you have to be
pretty forgiving to get into it when the
style and all-around coolness works I am
kind of forgiving of it it's not a lot
of dumb boring moments but the bad as
moments are enough for me to say I'm
glad I saw it
I know comic-book audiences are already
very complicated but hearing all this
you can hopefully figure out if this is
the right kind of gun for you or the
wrong kind of dumb for you I don't still
legitimately pissed off at the ending
just what the Joker coming in and that's
it I'm sorry I should have gone out on a
higher note well you know what this is
my take on Suicide Squad and I'm gonna
fix it I'm going to replace the Joker
with the one character I know would get
a gigantic reaction
[Music]
hmm
we know
[Music]
Oh
okay
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out and this week we are doing
feeding America this is the nation's
largest domestic hunger relief
organization together with individual
charities businesses and government we
can end hunger they provide safe and
nurturing places for children to have a
meal food that helps seniors meet their
specific nutritional needs emergency
assistance for disaster victims and a
chance at stability for adults trying to
break the cycle of poverty and hunger in
a country that wastes billions of pounds
of food each year it's almost shocking
that anyone in America goes hungry yet
every day there are millions of children
and adults who don't get the meals they
need to thrive they were to get
nourishing food from farmers
manufacturers and retailers to people in
need at the same time they also seek to
help people build a path to a brighter
food secure future if you look at their
site or their YouTube page you can see
the many different ways they use to keep
people fed as well as your many personal
stories about how they've helped it's a
great organization and you can be a part
of what makes it so great click on the
link below and see how you too can get
involved
Oh
[Music]